[ __ ] Rock Monday dude it's a ball suck
Monday ball suck Monday suck my nuts I
was hoping to your favorite team the
Seahawks would pull it pull it together
thought my favorite day yeah like
Russell Wilson though he is you know I
don't I'm not a football guy
I've as you know watched him got a
couple things to talk about one is yeah
he's ridiculously good
he's so ridiculously the NFL MVP Lamar
Jackson well I did and he's amazing but
he didn't really he wasn't able to pull
it off yeah I don't think give him the
MVP now I hate having to give it away in
the regular season
what'd she count all the way like doing
encompass the entire season because the
playoffs is when it matters most O'Brien
had a real tearjerker over I started
crying
I mean crying hard my stone was like
what's wrong daddy and I was like ah
when Jimmy Johnson was brought in the
Hall of Fame did you see that trade
clips I mean it was really cool man yeah
he couldn't speak and they surprised him
oh he had no idea was that yeah it was
so cool man what watch watch this it was
it was so cool
III saw it on I hope they have it oh
this is great watch this you're watching
live yeah again I'm not a football guy I
know what a legend he is though on
behalf of the Pro Football Hall of Fame
he has no idea at all now man that are
watching and all of us who love this
game Jesus Christ
nice Shrek given these [ __ ] man throw
hot for all you've done for the glass
Shrek in the hot seat you've ever seen
you know like you for the history that
you've made and the it lives that you've
impacted thank you it's my great honor
to tell you that you're going to be the
Canton Ohio forever huh it's distracting
how ugly that manit's
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that's the biggest guy in the world
yes yes next time yes Tony Gonzalez is
the only thing I can think of is all the
assistant coaches that have worked for
me all the great players have played for
me they're the reason I'm here and
they're the reason I can't talk this is
so special to me because the big and
you've put in the work that we put in
it's nice to know people appreciate it
Troy Aikman say me sitting there if you
see it on the big screen you can see
he's trying out each crime of course
yesterday Bill Cowher was announced and
again the blue suit connects on I found
my food like big now how he long is huge
how he longs to seventy no not anymore
no but he's a very big man now yeah but
look at that guy look at that guy
all of them can fit in his body you
talking about my thousand pound sister
well the third says look at his head
he's also just a giant man to begin
right there's no hold on me he's the
biggest man he's the big guys the
biggest man I've ever seen the eighth
shame a tumble out of the shot dude you
stole the camera away from Jimmy it's
all you [ __ ] up this emotional moment
for me my friend Brian over here know
everyone's like oh my oh my god he's
also a giant blue coat he looks like a
giant blue but then he blends into the
[ __ ] blue visa it's also good
nightmare what he the biggest
Jimmy's career and this [ __ ] whale of
a man comes in and gives him the order
like man who was made to play football I
wonder if he was a lineman or a d-back
um I think Jesus you know Christ
that's a beautiful moment that wasn't it
yeah it's cool man I mean Jimmy Johnson
deserves it yeah I am I got a lot of
[ __ ] on line for saying that Brad Pitt
was just okay which I was later believe
you said that yeah yeah tell you what
you should say what I should i'll please
the watch um do you see what I did I did
for the first time on the pole line hold
on yeah no yeah we came out seven months
ago
but but here's the thing about it well
here's the reason that was hesitant to
watch it so many people said that they
didn't think it was good they didn't
know where it was going in I read
critics and I'm like it's anything with
the Joker and I was like are you out of
your [ __ ] mind like I personally
thought it was a maze plan that I've of
all time lean on fire I wouldn't say
that with Leo DiCaprio how good is that
[ __ ] and Brad Pitt as good as
good and not character as it gets
amazing I mean it was a good movie I
love that movie such a good movie love
it but why y'all original that movie why
was I getting correct
but why would people gone it wasn't
about anything but booty why would you
the found critics but it was kneeling
actors and people I know and I'm what
think it's like what
I don't know do you ever drink it I know
you can't ever you can't have a virgin
what an effort
what our unique movie [ __ ] Tarantino
so unique you know what's interesting
and think about all the [ __ ] leading in
that movie where you know Sharon Tate
sister been like you know he's gonna
release this on the day of my my
sister's murder and he's highlighting
Charles Manson
didn't have anything to do with that not
at all and not only the ending spoiler
if you haven't seen it well for sure see
movies cuz I'm gonna say at the ending
the alternate ending how you're cheering
when he was seeing a woman's face in
your cuz they're the ones who merrily in
my wife Quentin Tarantino can get you
cheering I can't believe saying this
he's bashing her head into the phone
you're going like ice rod I felt
satisfied cuz I hated that I did in few
doubts like this yeah yes I know all the
I'm ballsy man stuff so when they're
taking her
ed and vram in the [ __ ] phone or that
dog's [ __ ] up early or DiCaprio has
his flamethrower now sit that [ __ ] on
fire no you know your taxes he did such
a good job of having you hate them ahead
of time
oh I'm telling you I'm I'm in the red
pit such a badass in that he's just such
a he barely a moodily see that's great
that's great so funny it was so great
yeah I'm always fantastic dude another
people saying it was a diss on Bruce Lee
shut the [ __ ] up have a sense of humor
this guy is he is Quentin Tarantino to
me has never gotten this to and III
believe cohort is to me I mean as an
actor didn't I think he's not I think
he's top three best directors of all
time right I don't think maybe would
argue with you Woody Allen
I got Woody Allen I got Stanley Kubrick
I got Tarantino
Scorsese's ridiculous and my favorite
but here's the thing about Scorsese in a
lot of ways he's he's very anything very
specific genre he doesn't have some
random shot and remember that your deal
you know Chris Christie's know right
Gosei isn't right Oh honest that's in
his speech or the going clubs he goes
usual I think to other riders and pretty
but I wrote this all myself I did this
all myself yeah cuz he you know he grew
up in Hollywood in the 60s and so he
wrote that bout his childhood and
watching those works at work done a
video games I worked in our video store
so he's sorry every movie there's no
Quentin Tarantino such a [ __ ] beast
he's impossibly talented but but Leo
DiCaprio is as good an actor I mean how
funny is how about when he was doing a
funny thing it's so good so good you
know that was all improv when he's when
he messes up the lines he's in his
trailer no but that was it that wasn't
written that I can pull just him
freaking out I'm sure I'll blow your
brains out self I quit drinking
it was so kick that's all improv I
believe I've been watching all behind
the scenes [ __ ] I loved it I loved it
that's my one way if not my favorite
movie I well I mean again talk about the
guy who did pulp fiction who did Django
who did for I mean it goes on and on
it's crazy Louis Pasteur wrote wrote
true rollers bastards inglorious bad
bastards Reservoir Dogs he's as he's
never made anything but a great movie so
I don't know I kind of marvel at that
[ __ ] people like that I marvel at is his
imagination and Harry plays with the
form ooh look at all those movies Kill
Bill [ __ ] I forgot about that
Kill Bill I never got another true dude
uh still done when I was a kid I have a
phallus that movie Natural Born Killers
mm-hmm Sin City a piece of that that's
Frank millinery but yeah mm-hmm
desperado
I don't know why is that a little Nicki
or the rock something else huh probably
had something to do with it pretty well
how do you saw because you were but
there are Joker's up for all the awards
another movie I [ __ ] loved what movie
Joker oh yeah don't eat now we just like
nuts just being in person but just as a
you know the fans will you know Jackie
yeah um I like I think they'll think I
think I'm wondering who wins the Oscar
the Joe hope for which Joaquin right for
Best Actor I can't win it dude how about
they didn't [ __ ] nominate my boy Adam
Sandler thank you that Janet they didn't
the only reason stays up is history no
no I think it's because they did a lot
of people haven't seen it came out later
so I think a lot of people I just didn't
get all 19 19 17 zoom out and that's
nominated for all this true that's true
yeah I think maybe it's history kind of
[ __ ] them they don't want them in that
club you know he's made over three
billion dollars I think they would like
him I mean he's never really accepted
him though well he's never done that
this is he's only done the couple of
roles were you know that would be worse
yeah is that is that for Leonardo Adam
driver Joaquin Phoenix no those other
guys can't it has to come down to I mean
a CEO like I agree a hundred percent I
agree and listen I won't be mad whoever
wins right now they say my girl Renee
that Wagner is a shoo-in
and I don't she's not up for that maybe
in supporting dude brat
dude that's a tough one
offset room for my dimepiece boyfriend
Brad Pitt in that but yeah Al Pacino how
about papa
have you seen oh yeah oh yeah III give
it to Brad Pitt over Pacino in a way for
that but Bale for sure over Brad Pitt is
oh I was looking at his arms I was
looking at he was so perfect for that
role like he just looks like an old
cowboy oh he's just dumped over yeah I
mean I guess not man cowboy but he is
the best-looking guy on earth he's a
rugged son of a [ __ ] he's up there man
yeah Sam look at Todd Phillips look at
that that's my boy right there
[ __ ] I hope he gets for the Joker
there's no way he'd be parasites a big
parasite the parasite might be the
sleeper yeah just watching it or do you
know have a see you have to watch it I
gotta see it yeah I gotta see a parasite
19:17 I have not seen me neither I've
seen everything else yeah have you seen
the marriage story I heard just falls to
marriage people are fighting all the
time
yeah I'm not watching it uh here's the
thing about me I see a couple hugging
and talking and it says marriage story
not watching it I'm sure it's people say
it's great Adam drivers amazing I bet
you're seeing the clansmen he's so
someone I saw him onstage and Broadway I
saw him and burned it I amazing right
very good he's so good are you what else
is up ninety do 1979 I mean I have to
see it now original scream the original
string player great what's a lot of time
in Hollywood has to win that I think so
keep going international where parasites
gonna win that all goddamn day right
probably keep going documentary Oh
American Factory I heard that wow I've
never I've never seen any of these well
no it didn't honey land animated let me
see i hain't seen those so I've seen how
to train a dragon hidden world my son
loved that I've seen Klaus you see I
mustn't Manik and I've seen toys dude
Toy Story 4 consult
so boring when I lost my
Ronny did you see I lost my body nope
production design don't care no I didn't
see that doom oh cool you should do cool
you guys care about that at all nope
alright film editing definitely not keep
going cinematography
okay keep go oh dude well I don't know
but Joker was such a mind-blower oh good
oh good
once upon a time like [ __ ] sick to
60s the late 60s and how they went down
Sunset you know he shot at night so it
was realistic and they shot sunset down
you know you know he had the actual the
neon logos rebuilt could put him up cuz
he want it to be so yeah On Point
yeah the restaurants they go to the
references Maslow drive and they show
where the murders happened there on
Cielo Drive that's not Stu master master
have you been up there to Cielo Drive do
you drop up there I did I was so scared
yeah oh yeah oh yeah so scared I want at
night by myself it was it eerie yeah
it's so creepy cuz you because you can
because it's a gate like to get up
there's a gate but you where they parked
to jump over to go up the street to do
the murders well you can go right where
they was there really an actor by that
name who lived next to the Polanski's er
no I don't fit all made all right what
no I made up there was it like a yeah
yeah yeah
what about that costume desired you're
like joking better or what's a fun time
in Hollywood I mean I I just was so
blown away by Joker so I'm I'm I don't
know it's the forefront of my Grasso in
not not by the way not the irishman
because it's suits in mafia so that's
easy dude once one time to Hollywood
this this this the [ __ ] style in the
60s is so goddamn good it's specific to
it so get it dude when Margot Robbie's
in the theater as Sharon Tate oh did I
mention squad she has her feet off he's
a she's a great actress beautiful she's
so beautiful I didn't become a victim at
home to you she's she's breathtaking
if Australia's on fire I'm saving just
or if I'm just bath pick one
or all the koalas I'm saving her you you
would carry her how far do you think you
carry her name a distance Jesus dude if
you put your back in your live in there
right instance you put it right up on
your back on him at this and I'd be
there supporting her breath swim the
Atlantic I would be like your breasts it
might get out of whack let me hold these
while he runs with you giant tits monkey
I know but I would just make sure
everything was okay that's fair sound
mixing nope what if she was like what if
Margot Robert was like hi I'm so sorry
to bother you guys I'm such a fan a
fighter in a kid and I'm heard it's
Cochrane Monday and it's kind of just
happy Monday so who's rocking some car
right now we'd be like well I guess we
are and then she'd be like she'd be like
oh this is I mean there's a motorbike do
you guys have the guts though to take me
on yeah I'd be elbowing you with a [ __ ]
out of the way I'd be making story oh
but she wants both he's got all kinds of
diseases oh but she likes both of us she
likes both of us dude there's enough of
everything to go around yeah he's like
Jamie songs Oh God hey this is one of
the awards you get Superboy dude you so
you know how homeboy who is hosting the
Golden Globes Ricky Gervais sweats so
hard in the paint and this cancelled
cultures like guest is hideous this is
awful
how could he do this no one enjoyed that
well what's interesting is he released
tickets for his toured the following day
now it's the fastest any tour has ever
sold out and he just signed a netflix
deal for like 70 million dollar of it
yeah so love it shows you where the yeah
like all that all of it online always
not real that's real yeah the real
people are like what no we can buy
taking all that [ __ ] out of here yeah
the real people but yeah yeah how could
you not love it see I don't know why I
just had this you know thinking about
Margot Robbie and nice thing about
sometimes like when you think a woman is
gorgeous I knew if anything about having
sex no I knew his famous dude who was
dating a super famous hot one of the
hottest women in the world and big model
this is by the way don't try to guess
because this was 10 years ago 15 years
ago and and I remember just looking
I was like this it was a my friend and
he was faint famous as [ __ ] and I was
with her and I was like looking at her
going she was like that she was like
that hot and I was looking at her and
she was so [ __ ] gorgeous that my
friend was my friend was kind of blowing
her off it was just a dick
and she was like and she goes so she
goes do you want to she asked him a
question he didn't really answer she
goes [ __ ] I go he doesn't answer
isn't listening she goes yeah he doesn't
listen you know he doesn't listen
because it's all about [ __ ] cuz if
you can give a good blow job that's all
you're worth let's be honest that's all
you worth right as long as I can suck
his dick that's all matters and she
walked away and I was like that's I
would marry you right now in my house
right I don't even know yeah I mean oh
yeah I won't I would even make you do
that if something got with me
remember she bursts on the scene from
doing um that movie Leonardo DiCaprio
Woolf philosophy of Wall Street you see
her left wall she right
they make humans that hot she's also
talented it's a design I was working the
Golden Globes two or three years ago I
was waiting for my car and she was
waiting next to me and she is oh really
left taking breathtaking yeah she's
breathtaking it also helps that she's
that good and talented come on dude she
could be making my [ __ ] chicken sales
at chick-fil-a and she's breathtaking
well how about how about Cindy Crawford
has her engineering degree did you hear
that and you know these nuts in your
mouth she just got a hearing degree I
didn't know yeah but did she get it like
how about you got it of course she was
famous look it up really you know some
celebrities like Alec Baldwin's time on
Stern how he got his degree from NYU so
he did four years but he never graduated
and then I mean here's this is ten years
ago seized by forty something cents for
30 39 38 so he says New York NYC wanting
to do something and he says assistant
what goes oh I tell him you do it but
Aspen cuz they went how can we repay you
Chemical Engineer Sinclair was a high
school valedictorian
bastard she attended Northwestern
University not an easy school to get
into on an academic scholarship she had
to drop it Crawford decided to pursue a
modeling career at the same time gain
international
either way she's a chemical engineer
that's not something can really just
breathe by I'm not gonna do now he's not
just me smart as [ __ ] yes she and her
husband's a stud - yeah he's a
billionaire
some people have everything beauty but
Alec Paul was talking about how
enlightened you receive do you want me
to do something yeah and his assistant
goes dude you'll have your treat tell
him instead of that they were gonna pay
him this huge sum because tell me what
your degree so he's like I'll do it but
he didn't even like degree in like okay
so he said he wrote a paper on acting
for them and they gave mr. grey I think
that's how I got my degree that's great
yeah yeah he's aren't this degree yeah
he's smart another guy on Broadway
streetcar named desire such a beast such
a great actor artifact at 35 no yeah
he's talking about on Stern he was like
a raging alcoholic and and cocaine user
he's doing all these lines he's on set
had a heart attack so then he got sober
from cocaine and narcotics didn't put
any tort just started doing alcohol
booze so he replaced with booze names
alcoholic then he got over that and now
he's been sober for years sometimes you
hear these like people go through so I
heard George Carlin who was my favorite
comic and I really respect but my the
people that do craft services they're
brother and sister team Marty and
Stephanie onions they were saying yeah
unschooled and they they went to they
were talking about how they went to see
George Carlin in Vegas and he was
[ __ ] amazing and they went back five
years later and they were soaks that
same exact act that was the back in the
day though I know but it was there it
was a ten-year period I guess when he
was using a lot of drugs that's all but
can you imagine doing the same act in
four five years I almost been towards
the end of his career though cuz they
give me specials yes so like ten and
tell you some shitty nuts but that's
right towards the enemies that yeah my
he's old yeah yeah damn are not to burst
your bubble but it says that she went to
school for chemical engineering but
dropped out so she's got one quarter
okay
but yeah it's begun but full-time you
know supermodel no but you know how
smart you have to be just to just yes
cool after a chemical engineering
scholarship that she's no joke yeah
she's no John so she's an alien
see goddamn alien yeah
god damn alien how's your neck don't
who's next better yours or Jimmy's
Johnson well me and my buddy my buddy is
52 we were talking like we're both I've
known since he was 14 and he was like
this is that I was like me to do stuff
don't [ __ ] say don't look at my
[ __ ] neck I like it's a sympathy case
don't go it's tough when Rossing fine
it's not yeah it is I have a good neck
goddammit you have a slinky for that I
do not have a slinky for a neck look at
you and Jimmy John no no we don't have
the same thing I don't why do that the
whole Famer yeah yeah that was really
cool big guy just I mean just completely
[ __ ] the thing up so much that it's so
funny I had to watch it you know I had
to watch it again cuz I got so
distracted by how big he missed it I had
to watch it again cuz I go that's the
biggest dude I've ever seen in my
[ __ ] life he's so big yeah yeah I
don't know if you know this dude but
when you put on your deodorant yeah
a lot of these dealers have aluminum in
a man so you're putting you're putting
toxins in your body
well they got parabens they got talc
they got aluminum it's not good it's not
good so thank God it's also tests on
animals sometimes dude but not I'm not
this the one I'm talking about to bring
to you I've thought about natives
deodorant it's made without aluminum so
you can feel better about putting it on
yo board remember that aluminum actually
plugs plugs your sweat claim applause
that's so good or plugs it but you got
native deodorant is safe its ingredients
you know it works the oil all right work
amazing cents over ten cents including
their classics and rotating cenotes when
I use which one I like to use the
cucumber and mint
well they got coconut and vanilla they
got lavender and rose and they got
eucalyptus and mint how about a little
free shipping on every order native
offers 30-day free returns the exchanges
in the US of A check out over nine
thousand five star reviews from happy
customers who made the switch to native
because they don't want them toxins in
their body all right you guys can get
20% off your first purchase by visiting
native deodorant calm that's na tive
deodorant
use the promo code t fat k during
checkout and you get 20% off your first
purchase native deodorant comm use promo
code t fa TK dude I was watching have
you heard of this show I would love for
us to do it never happening but I would
love to see how everybody never do it's
not 60 days in no so 60 days in is a
show on Amy we're 5 volunteers so you
could be an actor you could work for UPS
you could work for you could be a gym
teacher five volunteers go into jail for
60 days undercover yeah we talked about
everything
yeah but this new this new season which
just kicked off two weeks ago this new
season there's a guy he's a Pio so he
works in the prison they put him in
holding so the way it goes right they go
here's your story make sure your story
saw it cuz they sniff you out you're
pregnant shanked and died so just be
make sure your stories well when you put
you in general population guy goes cool
man he was the PIO has a whole family
goes you know I should I know it's like
for them it gives me perspective because
you know as POS were on the other side I
really want to learn perspective they do
this whole story they put them just it
goes holding then you're in with the
general population he's in holding and
they go here's the emergency sign that
you want out if you do this we we won't
ask questions we take you out of the
whole experiment you're out he's in
there for two hours and goes like this
and the producer you hear the produce
goes what no he didn't mean to do that
because and they they go they take an
audio what are you doing man we just
started us yeah I can't do it it's not
for me producer goes hey [ __ ] me
wait you haven't been in there and he's
like it's just I thought I could do this
and I can't then he couldn't he's on the
in the bus and the producer goes you
tell everyone's so disappointed because
there's a lot of effort goes you know
it's appreciators so what happened
exactly thinking is I was just in there
I thought I could do it and then he
starts crying and he calls his wife yes
I fail and she goes you just I just
talked to his I failed it he's crying
dude I was laughing so I
but also it's like why the [ __ ] would
you do that
yeah for 60 you leave your family
friends there's no payment there's
nothing so Harry comes sixty-day Harry
Connick jr. tell me a story about how he
was gonna do a role as a prisoner so he
decided to go up again to Angola no this
is after the Angola which is that prison
in well I think it's Louisiana I mean it
is it's the farm they did a documentary
called the farm it's a hell of a fight
Louisiana State it's where people get
kills maximum-security prison farm it's
it's not good our model days of
modern-day slavery and he he grew a huge
beard now here's the problem very famous
and his dad is the DA his fat dad is the
district attorney put all these guys in
jail so he's got a tractor with a long
beard and a dude comes up to him and
goes sup man there goes a man and Harris
Harris Creighton so town and yeah and
and and pretty big actually here's about
205 okay six - okay and Harry goes hey
man how you don't you know try to be all
that guy goes I know you are your dad
put me away oh oh and he goes it's cool
though I got you bro you just walked
away
they probably got him out right away not
I don't know I never cuz I last 60 days
in they tell them they go hey man
make sure your story straight cuz if the
inmates sniff out that you're trying to
be a snitch cuz that's what they do
right they learn all the secrets
then they snitch on him to the the chief
of the staff so he can correct what's
going on how they get drugs and stuff
like that so they tell him to make sure
your story straight this other dude he's
a Marine submarine he's there the his
story he's there for a night this old
head who's been there for six years some
[ __ ] comes out and he has a big long
beard he goes what's up man they get he
was what's up man they're talking and
the old man goes what you in for man
it's his first night he was what you in
for a man he gives him a Speleers
I had a DUI but it's on this military
base so I had in district County so they
took me over here and the old man takes
a beat who's been there so long seen
everything goes
yeah DUI on and names the basing of CAS
and they tranced you four counties over
here and he was yes that's [ __ ] man
ain't nobody believe in that you break
it your story straight man you say
because that's useful of [ __ ] and the
guy goes mm-hmm starts crying cuz mm-hmm
such crime goes into a cell he's like
[ __ ] roll its hurts cry but the old man
like because you know hey don't cry oh
dude it's so funny but the thing is is
like those real like they know so don't
man just wait hold up you're from
Cossack County yeah
that's four counties away yeah and
you're his TV blue eyes tell me that
that don't I see you guys that they get
your paperwork they get you all they
know they ask for your paperwork you
have to give it to them it's a sofa I
don't know if you're a snitch they know
every everything yeah that's why you
know where I went in Boston remember
when you and I did Wilbur three years
ago three and half four years ago when
we did what fine kid Wilberg yeah and we
worth Stevie yeah I went to that
Steakhouse strip at the sakai where the
[ __ ] it is and all those gangsters are
in there yeah so I take the crew there
Derek is Sanjay so I we get reservations
after we do Wilbur we go in there I tell
Derrick kiss on Jews with us that time
by doing hey this is like ran by
gangsters man Thome you know I don't
know don't do anything stupid boss oh
don't wear hats then I can let you guys
just come in with hats cuz they always
were these [ __ ] beanies and hats
dude we want another display why we
looked at I type down below the belt
well ya know so we walk in and ride away
like fellas
hats off like I [ __ ] around like told
you man get your happy I'm like that so
these were gentlemen
ah don't I told you dressed like a
gentleman to treat alleged gentleman
dressed like a punk and I treated like a
punk
no I'm saying that's my rule of life
y'all [ __ ] around those places that's
their spot that's that's old-school
Boston doubt he won't let Larry David
has an article in GQ we're talking about
how he dressed he wears like a hat and
us in a sweatshirt wherever he goes
because you get to level of Fame where
they respect you for that you can dress
like that he's like that's why I love
that lay I'm like homeboy maybe the
place is you going to LA I'm talking I
was with TMT about the height of his
career I'm talking V Tim Tebow
quarterback to the New York
chats ballin we had reservations at this
fanciest restaurant in LA there's a crew
of us we roll up we're dressed like [ __ ]
you like we're coming from the gym had
sweats because we came from doing
something we pull up you know Tim's
there goes a I've reservation and Tim
Tebow guys oh yeah I get to see a man
like some Medina's you're coming here
dressed like that
TV goes excuse me had a reservation for
like eight people who's gonna spend
hundreds and thousands of dollars the
guy goes you ain't coming here like
Denny's I I have a reservation and he
didn't wanna be like I'm Tim Tebow so he
licks to his brothers brother he goes
hey man we had this reservation for like
a week ago and the guy goes no no I get
all that you can come in be fellas you
have to go home and change and I was
like [ __ ] yeah
wow that's and the guy's like hell yeah
neither man I was so proud like [ __ ]
yeah dude yeah [ __ ] make him go home
and change
there's a little bit about there's my
father was always that way my father
comes ready to run father would always
be like we're a blazer
there's something about dressing
respectably that is part of a whole
you're the senior living room don't come
in sweat oh yeah it's even I heard I'm
not I'm not terribly you've never dress
like that but I appreciate I appreciate
what a place has it you was never going
to scope in no ads or a hat you gotta be
a little I told Eric and us on to I want
to do do you think it's bad in Boston go
to New York yeah go to new go to a nice
run and New York they do dude yeah
certain parts of they don't [ __ ] around
man and North should thing right now was
sure you gotta have some sort of it has
so much lacks now but it used to be way
they would have Blazers I've been to
restaurants where I was younger and I
had to put a coat on if they had a
blazer for me they keep Blazers in
letting up in a tuxedo but he can't be
in a gym sweatshirt and a baseball cap
right I do there's that famous
basketball player aha was it Jalen Rose
or Paul Pierce at I think it was STK
dressed in all gym and they were like me
I was the entire always a unibrow oh
Anthony Davis Anthony Davis right hidden
if the entire team was supposed to go
there but they're all in sweat
I can't come here he's like dude we're
gonna drop 20 G's like
that's that's fantastic you guys can't
come in here in your [ __ ] Nike
warmups
it ain't happenin it right it's
hilarious that's pretty badass you get
more you get more out of that anyway as
a restaurant cuz we talk about it will
you say you get more out of it it's a
good PR thing for the restaurant anyway
you're not allowed to come in unless
you're dressed up it makes news yeah
that's true it sets it up because I
remember I think it was Jelena or
someone back in when they first opened
cher wanted to change something on the
menu or one of these famous we do that
and Travis was like no sorry this is a
suggestion you can they're like what
she's like I don't eat dairy he's like
that's too bad then don't know that
don't order that I love that I may eat
for a made headlines and I love that and
yeah I got loved one restaurants like
what he doing first of all you're you
have you're good at singing are you good
at acting I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
say hey you're gonna shoot just get [ __ ]
out of here yeah I agree you're not they
um this is the policy sorry I can't
stand with people I've known celebrities
who who make people do the runaround and
it makes me and I've been witness to it
I've seen it there's nothing I hate it
and I hate it
I've seen I've seen some [ __ ] where I
was just like you gotta be kidding me
that you're doing this be pleased to see
these people you gotta be kidding me
it's bad people yeah what a tune it
catches up to you when you're an a-hole
what what the hell's going on no I don't
know hey man hey where were you this
weekend how about I said where we come
from I was coming from Nashville no how
was this amazing we've sold out all the
show
how's uh how's our boy the club Ryan
it's great I love him yeah love break
break and my favorite people hang out
yeah did you go to dinner and lunch with
him lunch probably I didn't have time
but it was so much he's the best yeah
weird it was it's it was the club was
great we are just Nashville's awesome it
was raining but yeah I sent Brendan the
weight the peril I'll send us here like
take a look at this disarm the the
Stuart send me a picture of the stage
tenant you're flying Southwest though
huh yeah the flight attendant was
or so I know well it's the only
direction yeah I know we're a direct
flight aware it and I bought a
first-class ticket you know what that
means
yeah 800 extra dollars a 283 right
I was 18 I know it's all this 89 and I
was like - it cost me way cost me 300
videos more and it can be a press outlet
get the Greyhound of the skies here I'm
not gonna wait like [ __ ] cows out
front get on number called
not Manny I like you in here so like are
you a 34 like that
I don't know I'm a 30 it's like I'm a 33
mind if I step in front of me all right
oh dude does it matter just go Jen I'm
going to send this to huh because I was
so impressed with her arm and then I
asked her she was like and the guy next
to me saw me take a picture he goes toot
I know look at her wrong I'm out and
before Brian so Brian sent his picture
goes check out for sure this and this is
what I said to Brian so brian says me
that picture I said oh my god my flight
attendant there you guys and he goes
suck him off bro I go and then I don't
answer cuz I'm like annoyed then I just
get well
did you oh my god shut up Brendan and
another another one suck him off throw
in the arm on oh my god that is
incredible that's a girl his na sukham
that is sucked it that's impressive and
her whole body was like that she was in
great shape oh oh I thought it was a no
attractive by the way attractive what
yeah great shape Oh older older like my
age maybe Wow
yeah hey I'm not trying to make fun at
least bit yeah he has a very similar
arms there's not a little more much
little more muscle but like similar
don't think that I didn't say that I
thought to myself her hands are bigger
st. we have similar arms their hands are
way bigger dude you shut a percent sure
I am I'm addressed although when I was
at The Comedy Store I was talking to a
couple of people and one of the women
was there
attractive very attractive
in heels 6:1 Arthur bottom yeah ok but
then I promise you there was nothing
nothing masculine I promise you as
feminine as it get besides our joint
technology's incredible and I looked at
my other friend and I went I'm gonna ask
you and my friend Sophia hey hold up if
you have to go hey I'm it was just such
a funny little thing in my and gave it
away the goatee no it's so girly I bet
you I bet you she chooses the only one
yes I'm sure I don't know I'm sure she
fools everyone she was gorgeous and
feminine and and I don't even want to
you know like I get it like sometimes
you're just a woman yeah I give it and
whatever that technology is they can ha
you know you yeah you she's a girl 100%
it's a girl a gorgeous girl but it was
weird how there was just that there was
something if you ever have to go hey man
do you but before the words do you think
it is yeah I've never met a hot girl
like is that a girl you know afro Stevie
had he was on that date with that girl
and I was again that's even did you hear
in Boston
no it's different that's not you talk
about the one that looked like Macho Man
Randy Savage with tits in high heels I
don't know I kept going is that it no I
don't know who you're talking about but
the one that know that is a hundred
percent a woman just a very in shape
powerful sexy woman that is that is the
queen of debt I would I'm gonna say that
I believe look like that Antrim I
believe it's natural you Brian you know
better that was not an attic to know
better dodge her her legs and asked for
way bigger than mine very impressed very
impressed
yeah no this was a different time this
was that this was at a restaurant
I met him and she was like hot but very
kind of over-the-top hot and I was like
what's going on with this girl and then
I went I looked and I said hey bro he
said seven years and I think that's I
think you might be getting fooled and he
said you know I've been wondering well
no here's thing if you've been wondering
you're right and he was said yet I've
never ever been on a date and they're
like is it yep
well she she was so over the top with
her tits and her half top crop top I
guys dig it I know and I was like and
she had waist Nass but I was like
something else
something I'm not making sense I don't
know why she's because she was trying to
be more girly than she was she was she's
pretending girl as opposed to being a
girl and then she also smelled like Old
Spice
well my mother said my mother said
something interesting to me so men have
a different body temperature men tend to
burn hotter than women do you know that
if their bites me and she said it was
probably the temperature of her skin and
probably the smell of her skin whether
you know it or not you're picking up on
these things and cuz Stevie was like I
don't know mom it's not she was she was
sitting like kind of I was like next to
him I'm touching him and stuff across
him and he goes I don't know bro I'm
just not attracted to I don't know why I
go Stevie that's because that's a young
man
Polaris it was wild yeah some would get
you man hopefully I mean our there I
think he did and I was like yes I mean
sometimes some summer gorgeous man yeah
so I'm a brown with a little orange
juice yeah you can be fooled sometimes
on my porn Abeka
you might like me I don't know why you
think I'd like that but yeah I'll take a
peek at it yeah it's in the truck to see
what's going on [ __ ] chicks with dicks
that's a whole different fetish that's a
whole different fetish that's another
thing other make up your mind you know
it's confusing
you look like Cindy Crawford just have
these [ __ ] roots hanging off the
front yeah
God's creatures you know like I'm gonna
be honest with you my own my own jizz I
avoid like the plague
Oh like like the idea that like you know
to taste it get there girl yeah oh my
god just like come here and I will see I
gotta wait second we gotta wait like T
if I get any of that I'm gonna go see
the [ __ ] out I know I'm very squeamish
about certain things I'm screaming about
stewed tomatoes and that [ __ ] do things
I can't have mine stewed tomatoes on the
screws stewed tomatoes those that burden
the egg though all in the balloon and
the balloon and and my own yeah just I
can't imagine someone else drive this
point home yeah I don't like I don't
like anchovies olives and Jess okay yeah
that uh in that order
anchovies olives in jail yeah I would
say I don't like just first and then
Angelus if you know that that would be
me but you you will take if you had a
class of anchovies a glass of although
yes no you're just said well that's like
how about in [ __ ] Fear Factor when
they had to drink tres between horse [ __ ]
and urine and I did it I did a whole
thing with women I said what would you
rather do and the girls were like
definitely they horse jizz I mean over
thank you hey I'll take urine all day
that you hear people would ask me like
oh how you know how do you think you do
on fear factor not good the physical
events all day tribal do pretty well
sure when it comes down to eating the
food I'm telling you I cannot do it and
dude this is um I just I have a horrible
gag reflex oh my my son my baby boy he's
like seven weeks old now I'll send a
picture of blow your [ __ ] mind I'm
saying speech so he gets congested you
know he's some weeks can't blow no no I
know I know you're so my girl has this
thing that's to this device you know
yeah cypher gasoline out if she does
that with him so will she doesn't suck
hard enough oh so I have to you guys I
didn't think much of it I'm like I'm in
bad I'm in my undies shows baby baby I
mean he's he's you know he's congested
we knew him get good sleep can you come
a goat
what she goes I can't get it out I need
you to suck into this to a oh I'm just
like second it's right for medicine or
somebody that and she connects his nose
are you what are you doing
she was you have to suck the boogers out
now you know what
okay this like a scat video I don't want
to she goes you just got to do it I wash
I might think of it so I go I think it's
on my mouth cuz it stops it so you don't
have to worry about book your skin your
mouth just the fact that that's enough
the suck it out yeah I'm tell the baby
look I'm talking I was going yeah and
what she goes what are you doing good
he's gonna wait that with the balloon oh
do you have to leave the room the worst
you've ever seen me dude
not for me oh I'm gonna show you this
[ __ ] house the set life be set life
is a lot of acting a lot of acting a lot
of repetition a lot of being the
background shot a lot of being somebody
shot all that stuff so it's a makeup
makeup it's early mornings up at 5:30
this morning that's always a lot of fun
will you I don't do well with mornings I
am NOT a morning person I'm a night
person because my job is at night I
spend my time performing a night I get
to bed at 2:00 I like to sleep till
10:00 that's how it is I got my eight
hours what happens is you got me up at
2:00 all the time because night owl
night Eagle and then I worship and I
don't you know you wake tonight eagle up
at [ __ ] 5:30 he's just getting into
his REM sleep not in a happy mood and I
got a jack I got a jam tough one Oh in
Nashville I went to Prince's hot chicken
and I got a mild so glad I got the mild
though I got the medium I got through
one [ __ ] chicken tender and I was
crying and snotting everywhere and then
you know what cuts you know what I
didn't know cuts all the heat nope nope
vinegar that's what really that's why
they give you the pickles you get a cup
of pickles and it kills the hot right
away
really it neutralizes the hot thank God
now
I ate all of the chicken tenders then I
had looks so good to poo yeah and I had
my green shoots on it would have been so
annoyed at me because my boy Brian
Cooley who has a baja Gracie at Franklin
in Nashville which is his jujitsu [ __ ]
he gave me he gave me a t-shirt and a
sweatshirt and because they were black
and I underpacked I wore my issue sheets
hell yeah dude it was awesome
representing oh damn rolls what a bunny
look anyone you had to put a huge giant
it's got four pubes
so rolls rolls but to suck the boogers
does no good to thing what a bunny I
know like ties him a lot used to kiss
him oh my god I'm all up in his grill I
stay on him they have no choice I know I
had a dance-off with my daughter
yesterday and I'm better dancer she beat
her well I'm a better dancer and I said
to my son who won he kept choosing her
which made me angry
then they snuck chocolate chip cookies
enjoy trying to keep a clean house with
kids enjoy that well my girl tight
yep you girls are different not all I
did it's a different level I problem
yeah problem really you ever seen my
house it's God it looks like
Architectural Digest we have before you
yeah he cleans up I've never seen it
like he cleans up I'm the dirty one no
yeah the tiger and you're pretty neat
mmm I mean I wish they leave stuff
around but my son and pick up stuff go
dad you're supposed to put this away
like really dude it's no like the snitch
bro wow wow she'd do some curt event me
neither it's kind of at it through an
event current events yo B yeah but it's
ready national championship is tonight
yeah the AFC NFC championships next week
you have the UFC this Saturday you'll
see 246 maybe you want to bet on the
underdog our boy Donald Cerrone maybe
you wanna bet on the favorite I think
the best bet maybe take Connor via
decision time out plus 750 son
if you want to watch fighting you watch
football make money doing it alright
make money doing it
you also have fantasy MMA I'm talking
about draftkings
if you haven't tried yet try draftkings
fancy MMA it's easy to play just pick
six fighters stay in the setup pile up
the points for advances take down some
more there's no better way to put your
MMA knowledge to the test then with
draftkings downright Yap
go to draftkings.com now use promo code
fighter at sign up compete for over
$300,000 in other odd news and don't
forget all new and existing users can
get a deposit bonus of up to $500 that's
promo code 5 fighter during signup and
claim your deposit bonus up to $500 only
a draftkings
minimum to $5 deposit required deposit
bonus requires a 25 x playthrough
eligibility restrictions apply see draft
kings.com for details okay this first
current event was sent in by Josh Hoyt
and there is a family court judge who is
currently on suspended paid leave
because there are allegations that her
her lover and her secretary often have
threesomes in the cohort when everyone
know what some fries god bless her her
her lover and all three but I think
that's hot unfortunately not leave her
alone
they should get fired no right now these
are still just allegations so there's an
investigation they're also trying to
look into other claims about her trying
to coerce people like her co-workers
into helping her get reelected there
were statements from people saying that
she would often retaliate if you didn't
agree with something that she did her
said oh so oh my can we pause for dinner
next our events okay so your boys your
boy Leonardo DiCaprio was actually on
vacation with his girlfriend and some of
his friends this past weekend and what
ended up happening was they were going
through a very specific route through
the Caribbean and they found out that
there was actually a man from another
boat who got
really drunk the night before while he
was at work fell off of the boat and he
was just stranded in the middle of the
ocean for 11 hours swimming swimming
they thought that he was dead because
the chances of him being alive and found
were estimated to be like one in a
billion
so you were more likely to win the
lottery twice than to find this man
relief and then you're found by Leo and
holy Shih szu found him because he was
like you know what instead of continuing
on let's see if we can find this guy who
fell off his ship they end up finding
him and rescued him after they went
looking for him they went looking for
him in the area that they found out he
got a real phone what Leo fella he was
treading water for 11 hours and doctor
says said that he would have had maybe
like a couple more minutes until his
body would have given out he's
dehydrated he was starving and it was a
white guy
yes French man Wow 30 year old dude
saved by Leonardo DiCaprio white man
mm-hmm I know why you asked that why I
know why because if he had been black
there is this assumption that kids with
that that that there's a body type that
would make it harder to stay afloat for
12 for 1100 know they always otherwise
and that's why you asked no I was just
curious that I I was very curious just
curious what kind of race I don't know
what race I was just very curious why
Brennan okay cuz he he was black he'd be
sunk like a stone nope do you have owned
I was driving can I take PCH
I saw seals dude oh yeah like seven
seals all out playing I'm like oh well
the L great white is now right behind
what greys are oh great right white cuz
they tell you whenever you see seals get
the [ __ ] out the water hot trail seals
sharks
that's right I want to sit there my god
I guarantee a shark jump ah that's
exactly what I want to know and I would
100% do that well on my way back we'll
see if they're still there I was at my
friend's house and
Malibu and the seal just came walking
out like that I was like right there at
the beach and you go paddleboarding mmm
would you him the stupid [ __ ] face
until I clubbed the [ __ ] out and then I
was gonna take his fur and I decided not
to and I left him there big ones are
iron hairy though I said flies need to
eat - yeah you're right yeah okay so so
this clip is going viral cuz the trainer
on the showed The Biggest Loser Jillian
Michaels was doing an interview and the
woman was started to talk about Liz oh
and how she loves her music and she
loves what she stands for with the body
positivity movement Julianne decided to
take him home and say why are we even
focusing on her body how long have I
been saying this how long have you been
preaching from the rooftop we should not
be celebrating this if you wanna be
confident that's fine be like eh I'm
trying to get better but this is me
right now my current state but I am
eating healthier that's fine but first
to celebrate obesity and just like
that's her no it's not
I know much food [ __ ] to eat in the on
discipline [ __ ] [ __ ] to do to get to
that level it's an addiction I was a
food addiction yep but she's gonna die
okay you told me if Julian Michael's not
spot-on
I personally found and I love
celebrities like Liz Oh or Ashley grant
the biggest host of all time and I love
her music
yeah well % I don't know anything about
her I'm sure she's a cool awesome check
yeah and I love that they're putting
images out there that we normally don't
get to see of bodies that we don't get
to see being celebrated and why are we
celebrating her body why does it matter
that's what I'm saying like why aren't
we celebrating her music cuz it isn't
gonna be awesome if she gets diabetes
well I'm just being honest like I love
her music like my kid loves her music
but there's never a moment where I'm
like and I'm so glad that she's
overweight like why do we why do I even
care why is it we have a problem with
this hair about her weight a lot of
people did why did it that's cuz they're
out of shape people did a lot of people
felt like she was fat shaming lizzo
which i don't think she was doing at all
she's just saying let's focus on her
music
she's oh sorry she's
repeatly we are all beautiful worthy an
equally desert also feels stronger that
we love ourselves enough to acknowledge
that there are serious artists that come
with obesity heart disease diabetes
cancer to name only a few I would never
wish these on anyone and I would hope we
privatize our health because we love
ourselves in our hungry Savior good
future I am Michael Sam yeah I'm not
with this movement like Oh everything's
beautiful hold on if you like fat chicks
or if you want to be a fat chick that's
your prerogative
but don't push the narrative on us that
this is the new and it's okay to look
like this B because it's it's not
healthy man it's not helping any facet
we're not meant to be that fat humans
are not meant to be that large
we're not she's her body she's
overeating that's cause that's s food
that's sodas so DS and my friends call
it Saudis I said she's not healthy I
like her music and listen it sometimes
some are post she's sexy but it's not
it's not healthy I think I think this is
where the jewel makers are so
professional trainer yeah don't fat
shame but at the same time let's not
celebrate the fact that she's insanely
overweight no here's my thing I'm not
gonna fat Shamer I don't give a [ __ ] if
she gets up to a thousand pounds but
what I do care if you've pushed the
narrative in my face and into the
younger generations face that it's okay
to be that fat right that's very that's
not a healthy message exact muzzle push
cigarettes
what's next cocaine yeah that's it as
healthy as this is this you know piece
kills more people that Lisi Mooney
left-wing or the loony woke or with the
loony whatever it is this is this
disease wackadoodles online and they're
just they're just noise but but people
were given Julie Michael [ __ ] you think
those people are all healthy and they
don't say matter like you said again it
doesn't know the real boots on the
ground no one gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] and they
know she's right they know Jillian
Michaels is right everybody no no no
she's out of shape
dude when she's 40 and she's looking in
the mirror and the doctors like hey man
your cholesterol so high like it was
queued up for her diabetes now your
body's in number one gotta start eating
healthy diabetes make you go blind you
know she's like oh this doctors fat
shaming me no no we just we want you to
live long you're like your music yeah
100% that's the truth but yeah this one
she said to her yeah Liz oh went onto IG
live and she made a small reference to
it play basically this is why my name is
in your mouth I saw was my [ __ ] [ __ ]
enjoy the flavor
that's my job yeah that's that's a
basket that took you like yeah gives a
[ __ ] about Liz oh well I like fat and
that and you should lose weight for your
poor effort because I want you to be
healthy and live longer yeah how's that
that shit's not it spits the truth
you're you're telling the truth do you
want to have a talk with me if I was 300
pounds or more a job dude you gotta
chill out dude I mean I can't do the
podcast but you're so mean yeah how
could you do this to me like you on the
ground mic will fly my names in your
mouth but dicks in your mouth we'd have
to change broadcast to 10 because I'd be
the number one you'd be the number zero
cuz you're all fat this is kind of
related I guess remember this guy
Ethan suply from Remember the Titans
dude remember from American history yes
right here boom I don't remember he's
always been like on TV he's always a the
fat good you know the fat guy always the
fat guy in every show and movie huh you
ever seen him now hit it Byam
so he lost a lot of weight and he's also
packed on muscle it looks good man yeah
Wow that's what [ __ ] uh well the
first up game well American glutton
podcast is up please enjoy I might have
listened that huh
that's impressive very impressive my
people might be a little hormonal help
to good friend I mean you know even even
with that who care that's so impressive
it's awesome
it's awesome what a difference keep
going
what a [ __ ] diff don't hear a piece
of it yeah couldn't look better couldn't
look this idea now that food was
something that people didn't want me to
have so if I wanted to have
more I needed to do it privately and it
became something that I was withholding
from people I actually realized later in
life that much of my binge eating came
on my own when I was a teenager I'd go
out to a night club with my friends I
never really felt comfortable eating in
front of people but when I'd go home I'd
always find a 24-hour drive-through and
eat three meals you know in my car like
before bed which you know today seems
crazy because I don't eat after dark now
I have this doesn't he not well and
we'll talked about the SAS has talked
about this on the podcast it's the same
kind of thing yeah that becomes an
addiction it becomes a thing that you do
and it's also fun it's hard to break you
know yeah it's also a lot of fun stopped
at Wendy's you could only 73 you can eat
three no I can't I don't need a lot you
know can't do that I could you actually
don't I don't eat that much I could stop
and get on number one on Wendy's and
then eat that yeah and then I'll have
some shaming Gail like pie if it's a
round like sweet stuff like when we got
a juicer you'll be like some of those
desserts but what once I don't have it
then I don't like the first three days
I'll crave it then after that I'm good
we hain't been to juice now ever ever
that's why I want to go that they're
that [ __ ] Italian hoagie if you had
the Italian of course I have their whole
thing their the burgers get there the
pizza will been there forever it's gonna
walkie and I got rhinos work all you do
is work dude you wrap this [ __ ] show
she March mid March that should be some
time yeah how do you guys spell the name
juice nah don't worry about it she jus t
f G jus ta give us one discount okay
alright let's go this one was pretty
crazy so this is a New Zealand and they
had their six-year-old daughter just
waterskiing and then there's an actual
orca underneath that you'll see a jet
take a look around that's trouble those
killing whales are [ __ ] do no they
don't they don't kill human means in the
wild everybody cuz Joey in his place in
New Zealand they'll swim right under you
he showed me a video of him
got skis okay legs all day too it's like
in a little bay area - it's not even
like the lady who died at SeaWorld beg
to differ whatever well that was
different though because yeah it's and
that was that that that whale was in
captivity but never in the wild is no I
know we've seen moment let me know if
you guys can even see where it is
all right
so far oh I see him right through that
thing how freaky is in the boat
oh it's so creepy when I see that too
and then listen to the family where they
add New Zealand
[Applause]
the only good thing if there's killer
whales around there's not gonna be great
whites around great whites are terrified
of killer whale we're here
hey killer whales aren't gonna hurt
usage they're yelling out there's a
killer whale when the little girl is
just skiing ya got the sister way to go
sis it's the mom telling the son her die
yeah what's that that's just some other
video
it's just don't kill her what I would
yeah a heartbeat
that is just okay creepy so cool I don't
know they're [ __ ] killer I would want
a hundred percent so I'm gonna kill her
well oh I would speak to it and I would
write it spin right there's three on
like that I did like Aquaman I'll punch
him in there you're gonna die if you're
gonna die some way that's the way to
[ __ ] go and I will oh that's that's
amazing that's for them actually come on
dude that's a baby look at the baby
following him there so just hit it with
it with your [ __ ] propeller have you
ever scuba dived uh yeah are you lying
to me yeah cuz I don't want to hear
about yours damn you're lying I lie all
the time but what so please talk about
the time you know because what's cool
about it is that when you scuba dive
you're under the water I was in Tahiti
us and you can spend 40 minutes
underwater and everything moves in slow
motion and you you would want to spend
your life down there like I can see how
you can see how Aquaman came about
that's how it is I want to be Aquaman
you know to be able to do that on the CN
don't you lie when people do that dude
you've never seen I'm like oh I have
seen it please don't tell me about it
yeah I do that all the time
dude you've never seen God farm like oh
no I have seen it in a combo
never seen you've never seen Goff I have
nobody out part women to have not seen
that I've seen it dude phenomenal you
kidding me dude
you're not film literate if you haven't
seen their amazing y'all hold up still
yep you're right let's go it doesn't
hold up
Sopranos when's last time you watched it
Brian a long time go back and watch it
the [ __ ] out of my face with that show
Wow no y'all watch it second season they
say the second season I stopped after
one I just can't
it's Italy like some of the storylines
our instrument as far as like compared
to shows now good god it doesn't know
how stated yeah
super dated what do you mean by dating
what is it just the whole destroyed put
together like that just then do it it
was the first if it's don't at me was
the first one when you why when you go
back to watch the first one mm-hmm you
don't have context it you ever watch the
first season of Simpsons it was so
ridiculous
that's what Sopranos is oh good first
season Sims is not good I mean the story
is good but it's like they care you like
what the [ __ ] compared to now or
compared to like Rick and Morty you're
compared to like Pixar [ __ ] do it like
you can't won't you watch like a Pixar
movie can't go back and watch like
Mickey on that steam [ __ ] boat you
know that's what it's like yeah it's
true some movies just don't hold up like
like you see the cutaways and how they
do it dude like dust O'Donnell was my
[ __ ] growing up as a kid yo Mike how
much Dustin there's a movie there's a
movie Sheila's corneas I think it's
predator or it's one of these [ __ ]
movies where the Kai's decide what's up
buddy in the soldiers and they make
shake hands yeah some of this yeah see
their arms in oil their arms well the
end prom do you like this is so
embarrassing they're both in tank tops
and they tuck their tank tops in and
they're supposed to be soldiers like
nobody dresses like that you found no
one's oiled up either nobody to oiled up
certain movies you go back and watch
like Jesus Christ like even the rocky
when they're both sprinting and they're
both oiled and like hey dude you guys
are you're wearing these hi shorty was
just a different time yeah you know what
it was there was no irony it was like
literal everything was very literal you
know it was very on very on the nose
I gotta get West Palm Beach up on the
website which I haven't told Jay about
Cleveland hilarities January 30 31 one
two weeks yeah two weeks right and then
I got West Palm Beach improv for a dive
ride a Saturday Sunday
that's the thirteenth fourteenth and
fifteen fifteen and six that's right
yeah West Palm Beach I'm excited dude
I'm in San Jose this Friday Saturday
Sunday because Martin Luther King is
Monday so Friday Saturday Sunday San
Jose
improv come see me Friday Saturday
and the next week I'm in Charlotte
comedy zone Charlotte January 23rd to
the 25th and then I end January in Ohio
Columbus Ohio at the funny bone January
31st through February 1st San Antonio
just got announced that is February 6th
through the 8th then Ontario for
Valentine's Day weekend that is February
13th through the 15th and then one show
in Vancouver for jfl that is at Vogue
theater almost sold out that is February
21st Vancouver get your tickets tea
vodka calm for Bryan myself that's right
that it dude that's it bud thanks ring
so back and do some [ __ ] acting do
drink it up bro there's the five kid
route